من ولايه ايديمان التركيه وهذه الصور
الاولى لما يشبه المعجزه حيث تم انقاذ
سيده مسنه تركيه تبلغ من العمر سبعه
وسبعين عاما بعد انقضت 200 واثنتين عشره
ساعه تحت الانقاب اذا نشاهد في هذه الصور
فرحه فرق الانقاذ التي نجحت في انتشال هذه
المسنه التركيه بعد اثنتي عشره ساعه قضتها
تحت الانقاذ تسعه ايام على بدء هذه
الكارثه التي تسببت في مقتل واحد واربعين
الف شخص في تركيا وسوريا واصابه اكثر من
100 الف اخرين اذا سنشاهد صور انتشال هذه
المسنه السبعينيه
بعد
عشره ساعه قضتها تحت الانقاض
خرجت حيه
وتحمل الان في هذه الصور
من قبل فرق الانقاذ والاسعاف التي
تنقلها الى سياره الاسعاف
في ايدي يمن التركيه هذه
معجزه تقريبا
تسعه ايام مسنه تبلغ من العمر 77 عاما يتم
انتشالها وهي على قيد الحياه في ايدي يمان
رغم مرور تسعه ايام لا زالت فرق الانقاذ
في تركيا
تتمسك بالامل بالعثور على ناجين هذا اليوم
شهد ايضا في ايديامان انقاذ طفل عمره احد
عشر عاما
وقضى ايضا
مئتين وسبع ساعات تحت الانقاض
اذا اذا امان اليوم تحتفل
باخراج هذه المسنه التي تبلغ من العمر 77
عاما ونشاهد فرحه فرق الانقاذ يهنئون
بعضهم البعض بعد ان نجحوا في انتشال هذه
السيده
واقارب المسنه ايضا
يهنئون ويشكرون عناصر الانقاذ بعض من
هؤلاء هم من اقارب المسنه الذين كانوا في
عين المكان وقاموا بشكر فرق الانقاذ على
جهودهم
اذا هذه يبدو انها تصريحات
باللغه التركيه لاحد اقارب المسنه ويعبر
فيه عن امتنانه وايضا احد فرق الانقاذ
والاسعاف يعني فرحه
اليوم اكثر من مره باخراج ناجين رغم مرور
تسعه ايام على هذه الكارثه التي ضربت جنوب
شرق تركيا وشمال سوريا ايضا
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ اليوم من انتشال
فردين من عائله واحده في هاتاي
في اليوم التاسع من هذه الكارثه عائله
مكونه من سبعه اشخاص تم انتشال شخصين في
هاتاي فرحه عارمه اذا في ايديمان وفي عموم
تركيا مع استمرار انتشال ناجين بعد تسعه
ايام على بدء هذه الكارثه جهود الانقاذ لم
تتوقف ابدا في تركيا رغم مرور تسعه ايام